Aww Yeah!
Today we are learning English
with Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban.
You know, this was actually one
of my favorite books and movies
of the Harry Potter series because it's kind of
when we start seeing the characters
becoming adults.
And so the movie had a bit more
of a level of maturity than the first two.
And, by the way, if you're new here,
every single week we help you
to understand fast-speaking natives
without getting lost,
without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles.
Just like Daniel, who says that he thinks
we are the number one channel for learning English.
And we're excited to join you
on your journey to English fluency too,
All you have to do is hit that subscribe button,
and the bell down below
so you don't miss any of our new lessons.
Now, let's roll over to Hogwarts!
Hey! I've got a question for you:
Would you like to be able to understand
natives no matter how fast we speak?
Then, why not try our Fluent with Friends course?
In this 48-week course,
every week you will get a lesson
that teaches you English following along
with the first two seasons of the series Friends.
Plus, you get 20+ Page PDF Power Lessons,
Access to our Fluency Circle global community,
vocabulary memorization software,
and so much more.
And you can try it for FREE right now.
What are you waiting for?
Just SIGN UP for our Masterclass
by clicking up here or
down in the description below.
Hey, Harry Potter fan! If you are a muggle
who is fascinated with the Wizarding World,
then be sure to check out all of our lessons
featuring Harry Potter
in this playlist after you finish this lesson.
Aww Yeah! I hope you had a lot of fun
joining me in the Wizarding World today!
And if you want to get English fluency
magically fast,
then why not hit that Subscribe button
so you don't miss any of our lessons
featuring movies like Harry Potter,
and series that you love?
Now, it's time to go beyond the classroom
and LIVE your English!
Aww Yeah!